do you have advice for young people who
are looking to go into a career in
journalism I think just kind of
accepting the reality that there's no
mainstream journalism anymore that's
just going that's one thing just
understanding the reality of the
environment and then the other thing I
think is just like experiences
everything and don't worry about making
a huge Splash right away until you have
like mastered the writing or mastered
being on TV I've seen a lot of people
really want to share their opinions very
quickly out of college there's something
to be said for just humbling yourself to
the idea that other people might have
something to teach you for the next
several years and just learning the
craft learning the trade and then going
for it